[Music]
and snitched on your self news oh I do
that all the time
submitted by Gio's fourth child fourth
what's your two and three that for the
future this one was the fourth one
because I already have three four babies
so [ __ ] spy this one oh hey Oh a New
York state court spokesman butt-dialed a
reporter and left an accidental
voicemail bragging about how he barely
shows up for his $166,000 job that's a
great oh and then he gets a tickin away
from him no that never happened it took
all his toys away oh he went on paid
leave yeah exactly yeah you were not
double paid leave what's his job again
so he is a New York state court
spokesman ever since 1986 so he he
handles press inquiries on court he's
the guy at the podium with like the 200
Mike's in front of him yeah oh [ __ ]
daddy that you watch onto news day you
watch no you always watch him before you
watch the person you want to listen to
yeah
like the sheriff or the [ __ ]
wait the job of where you get to talk to
thousands and thousands of people at one
time that's the job you want I don't
that's I mean stand up you talk to like
a large crowd of people you're on
YouTube dude and you talk to thousands
of dollars oh it's true we can't see
them on YouTube oh no we barely show up
do you don't wanna show up and you can't
be booed because you just saying basic
[ __ ] like yeah this is the trial then
the by someone else
I think it's even lamer than that I
think it's just like I just weren't
introduced right now Fairfax County
Sheriff Roy Goodman like you never you
never want to hear what that guy has to
say he's the guy that introduces why is
it always again this is the guy can it
be a good nobody wants to hear a woman
talk about that true that
true I can't wait to read these calm
yeah mate why are you guys discrediting
this dude maybe he like worked really
hard to like nobody so hottest you
notice stupid bragging you probably put
in his time to like be where he's at you
know like what are the steps to you have
to go through some auditions like what's
the step context is important a lot of
parking tickets going to auditions first
up she hosted PTA meetings at first just
to like climb the ladder I don't know
all the context is so important cuz if
he's talking to like some chick that
he's gaming on just a lot of [ __ ]
money
it's no big deal I guess to me like then
I'm like okay I know why he said that
he's a douchebag but I get why he said
it right maybe not very important saying
that or maybe talking to his mom he's
like mom I wish I could make it to you
cancer treatment that's I got the money
it is a good center see that he's a good
at son on something but you're so busy
no I barely have to show up like they're
driving you have to if the prioritize
that otherwise they could do Freedom of
Information Act on your under workflow
oh yeah corner there's actually an angel
and this reporters a dick he's a good
man going down I don't like I don't like
David he's Augie sound shady already
David he's 58 years old and so he ended
up getting this job after working as a
director of public information for the
city's former emergency medical service
told you he had a climb up the ladder so
he works at the information desk music
sounds like a bunch of [ __ ] in a row
that's what he days they make up these
city jobs I thought they do these things
for like their friends yeah oh yeah he
was stripped of his spokesman duties
after there was a change in leadership
last year so since last year he he
doesn't really need to do the little job
that he has been hired to do because
someone else is doing it what the [ __ ]
because I guess like administration's
like they do favors for each other so
so they let him keep his job and his
pension and like a salary and everything
hey and we're paying for the witch's
text was funded a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] though I guess like he was on a New
York Post reporter was contacting him
for a different story and that's when he
accidentally butt-dialed him and then he
was having a conversation with other
people and in that conversation he's
just saying how he lied to the reporter
he barely shows up to work and that some
weeks he only works two days he hasn't
worked a Friday in at least three years
you're just like saying all this stuff
like who while he was but knowing him
right who's he talking to by the way
he's talking to like a twisty villain
yeah the taste is help like who is this
guy who were his friends right yeah yeah
I want to know who's talking to the
other billion yeah corrupt politician or
something yeah they're in a circle how
is this reporter able to validate
whatever statement he's making because
it's not like he can record it Oh cuz he
left a voicemail for me it was a voice
give me a four minute speech Jesus
you did it villain monologue that's so
good I actually had the audio or I have
the audio but it's just it's so bad it's
not even worth playing for you guys but
that's just pretty much of you thing in
the voicemail so you caught him talking
to his mom for four minutes explaining
that you can visit her and the cancer
treatment this stuff and the reporter
just trying to stretch and twist
everything around yeah exactly
reporters jealous they hate us because
they ain't us man that kind of goes up
no I love that people who work their
[ __ ] asses off right they come home
they work they work [ __ ] eight hours
a day or longer or 12 hours a day or
[ __ ] 50 hours a week they can't they
can't buy a house but this cat has 166 K
clearing easy with his scummy ass
government job works two days
he's just banking in banking shots while
a lot of good people have no shot well
they're paying for it that our weeks to
pay for this guy Oh taken out of their
paycheck I wonder what he does on his
free time cuz he has a lot of free time
Koff membership were you seeing to
thanks moona so this guy he's 58 right
so he was set to retire in October he
would have been 59 by then
so they're saying that his pension would
have had a 21% cut if last year when he
he got his duty stripped if he would
have been let go at that time his
pension would have been cut by that much
right but then now since he stayed a
little longer his pension penalty would
be only 15% but still like he's still
gonna be getting what taxpayers are 35
percent fighting after getting caught
now this is what David said and he has
been let go now it's big job if he's
like I was talking to my mom but no one
will believe well he's been like oh but
he still gets to keep his pension
exactly so here we go but frankly look
the bottom line the story is true I'm
not doing anything
I barely show it to work and I've been
cut I don't need to show up because they
took away my responsibilities and left
my pay they left me alone and look I
have a big mouth I told people I'm not
doing much I kind of asked for it you
know if you have a big mouth you know it
ketchup catches up with you look so
Italian you keep saying look a lot a lot
of bottom line let me get to the point
I'll suffer through a terribly
embarrassing story and then go get my
[ __ ] pension and retired you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're not even embarrassed
you [ __ ] scumbag this is David yeah
he always was like a scumbag I like to
judge people on looks really on 4:58 I
just like to point that out yeah
probably cuz he can pay for all the
facials down girl God he's the one that
[ __ ] girls when they're drunk that's
that guy he goes to the bar puts a
little roofie in their drink that's that
guy never saw his face there we don't
trust him cuz he's you know with all
that free time he has nothing else to do
but to roofie up girls he couldn't even
make roofies it's like you can save her
you could tell the sweet talks by those
shape of his mouth where is he crazy an
East Coast guy yeah
hey but the bottom gonna show up and I'm
gonna
my retirement hey you got a big mouth
you know it caught up with me I'm gonna
take like a steak all times are the same
hung us yeah we make pasta and pizza in
there and that's a woman I know I know
I'm trust me I met one I met them all
trust me one of them are now I know all
speaking about Italians in France the
hosts the best food I've had Italian do
when we're in Amsterdam eye candy and
food was the best food we have in
Amsterdam what's Indian Amsterdam she
was the fam mm-hmm but yeah I really
enjoy Italian food in France
I mean fellas really did make it so
clean and then front French food is just
so heavy
yeah yeah cream your head foie gras that
tastes like [ __ ] because I have I will
come on you never accidentally a little
bit like you know licked a finger after
some [ __ ] okay yeah you're like okay
yeah let me ask you this have you ever
that's dick juice okay but but it also
came out of you know but I don't know
you just said good Nick after it
wouldn't I did but I don't know because
it's not genuine it's been crossed I see
you're saying I wonder why his dick or
good because then it's also hard to
tastings when you're aggressive minded
that's true that's very true yeah I feel
like I've tasted a dick before and I've
tasted after and so I take away the
difference you know
[Laughter]
this very expensive restaurant very
expensive restaurant and they brought
out the foie gras and it was like dipped
in some whatever-the-fuck
and that was like this tastes like it
did like when you talk about it tastes
like [ __ ] you're not talking about
candy yeah yeah no no no that wasn't it
it was the other one the one that was
like it had like a brown sauce or no one
that [ __ ] just doesn't taste good like
no one's like oh like this is the best
[ __ ] of every flavor
it depends man there's a there's a
viscosity to it acquired taste just like
wine and cigarettes right it's like do
you like for example you like McDonald's
sweet and sour sauce never had it then
you never had this hope you guys enjoyed
that video but if you didn't guess what
you can directly contribute to the
articles that we discussed just cruise
out over to the description box below
click on that link to submit your
article also for the next video like
right up hey
[Music]